if you want to know how billionaires
like Jeff Bezos Mark Cuban and Oprah
Winfrey think act and make decisions
then this video is for you
we all have adversity in our lives think
about what you do as a consumer what is
it that makes you make the choices that
you make why do you buy a certain thing
why do you shop a certain place it's
very difficult for me to even see myself
as successful because I still see myself
as in the process of becoming successful
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out onto the world so today we're gonna
learn how billionaires think success
advice from the top vol 8 enjoy up first
at number one is choose to do the hard
things with Jeff Bezos we all have
adversity in our lives yeah I would I
would I doubt if you really you know if
you know somebody any friend or anybody
that you talk to there's no lack of
adversity and the and by the way that's
good because it's what teaches us how to
get back up you fall down you get back
up it always happens and you know you
get certain gifts in life and you want
to take advantage of those but you like
it's my advice on adversity and success
would be to be proud not of your gifts
but of your hard work and your choices
so you know you may be the kinds of
gifts you get let you know you might be
really good at math it might be really
easy for you that's a kind of gift but
practicing that math and taking it to
the next step that could be very
challenging and hard and take a lot of
sweat that's a choice you can't really
be proud of your gifts because they were
given to you you can be grateful for
them and thankful for them and but your
choices you choose to work hard you
choose to do hard things
those are choices that you can be proud
of number two is create memorable
experiences with Mark Cuban when people
think about going to sporting events now
use this as an example you don't
remember the jump shots after a while
you don't remember the homeruns you
don't remember the touchdowns you don't
remember the score you remember the
experience yeah you know remember who
took us your first game with our mom or
dad we remember how we felt when we won
that game you know going to a sporting
event it's one of the few places where
you're allowed to stand up and scream at
the top of your lungs and you're
encouraged to scream as loud as you want
and someone hits a game-winning jumper
you're hugging people and high-fiving
people you've never seen in your life
and you'll never see again and you're
walking out of the arena you know
singing and chanting and screaming and
if you lose that game you're bummed out
and you know the entire city or the
entire school can be bummed out so when
we sell when we seldom average we don't
sell basketball we sell unique
experiences and so you've got to
understand in your business exactly what
the differentiation is and what the
compelling aspect of that business is
but you know think about what you do as
a consumer what is it that makes you
make the choices that you make why do
you buy a certain thing why do you shop
a certain place why do you go to a
certain website those are the keys
number three is demand respect with
Oprah Winfrey when I first started as a
broadcaster I was 19 very insecure
thrown into television pretending to be
Barbara Walters look in nothing like her
and still going to college so I do all
my classes in the morning from 8:00 to
1:00 and then the afternoon I work from
2:00 to 10:00 and did the six o'clock
news and would stay up and study and all
that stuff that you know until 1 2 or 3
o'clock in the morning and then just
start the routine all over again
and my classmates were so jealous of me
that I remember like taking my little
hundred and fifteen dollar paycheck and
at the time I thought was really a lot
but taking 150 dollars and trying to
appease them I would like all wait
anytime anybody needed money I was
always offering oh you need ten dollars
or taking them out for pizza ordering
pizza for the class and things like that
trying to that whole disease to
that's where it was the worst for me I
think because I wanted to be accepted by
them and could not be because first of
all I didn't have the time they wanted
me to pledge and I didn't have the time
to pledge I was I didn't have the time
to be a part of all the other college
activities or a part of that whole
lifestyle and it was very difficult for
me socially really one of the worst
times of my life because I was trying to
fit in in school and be a part of that
culture but also trying to build a
career in television it's very difficult
for me to even see myself as successful
because I still see myself as in the
process of becoming successful to me
successful is getting to the point where
you are absolutely comfortable with
yourself and it does not matter how many
things you have acquired the ability to
learn to say no and not to feel guilty
about it to me is about the greatest
success I have achieved the fact that I
have you know in the public side done
whatever is fine it's all a part of a
process for growing for me but to me to
have the in the kind of internal
strength and internal courage it takes
to say no I will not let you treat me
this way is what success is all about
it's the same thing that prevents you
from being abused as a child that
prevents you from being abused as an
adult that allows you to build success
for yourself I will not be treated this
way I demand only the best for myself
you are worthy to say no you were that
it's okay if you say no it's okay if you
say no and then people don't like you
that's really okay the important thing
is how you feel about what you're doing
how you feel about yourself it's a long
struggle though it's a long struggle and
I'm just hoping that you know in the
work that I do on the show and the
speaking that I do around the country
and that young people who are watching
this can get the lesson sooner than I
did because it's painful because you
keep repeating it over and over and over
until you get it right and what I found
is that every time you have to repeat
the lesson it gets worse because it's
you know it's I call it God trying to
get your attention the universe trying
to get your attention so we didn't get
your attention the first time so we're
gonna have to hit you a little harder
this time
so I'm still doing it I'm still learning
number four is assign yourself the right
story with Warren Buffett well in 1973
the Washington Post Company gone public
in 1971 right about the Pentagon Papers
type time but in 73 the Nixon
administration was through bebe rebozo
who was a pallid Nixon's they were
challenging the licenses of two of the
Florida television stations to post own
so the stock went from 37 down to 16 now
it's 16 there were about 5 million
shares outstanding so the whole
Washington Post Company was something
for 80 million dollars and that included
the newspaper for big TV stations
Newsweek you know and some other assets
and no debt to speak up so the
Washington Post Company which was
intrinsically worth four or five hundred
million dollars was selling for about 80
million in the market
we've bought most of our stock at about
the equivalent of a hundred million in
the market and and it was it was
ridiculous I mean you had a business
that unquestionably was worth four or
five times what it was selling for and
Nixon wasn't going to put them out of
business when you're doing these
analyses then and now do you have
computers that help you or how did you
actually read all what you just get
written materials or how to do it in
those days get the materials to read
about the Washington Post and how do you
do it today well the same pretty much
the same way except there's fewer
opportunities now but I met Bob Woodward
back and and and he'd just come out with
all the Presidents Bano and all of a
sudden is that all thirty years of age
he was getting quite wealthy and we had
we had breakfast served lunch over at
the Madison Hotel he said what do I do
with this money and I said I said
investing is just about assigning
yourself the right story I said imagine
Ben Bradlee this morning said to you
what is the washington post company
worth what would you do if you have to
write the story in a month you've got an
interview TV brokers and newspaper
brokers and the owners and it's a crime
value each asset I said that's what I do
I assign myself the right story and it's
it's nothing more than that now there's
some stories I can't write if you ask me
to write a story on you know what is
some glamorous but non profit making
business worth I don't know how to write
that story but if you ask me to write a
story on what is Potomac Electric Power
or something like that I
I can write the story and that's what
I'm doing every day I'm assigning myself
a story and that I go out and so you get
number five is solve problems with Peter
teal I actually think you should think
twice before starting certain types of
businesses so I think there are probably
too many bad businesses getting started
and not enough good ones so that's it's
you know it's I don't think there's I
don't think there's anything about
entrepreneurship per se that is that is
is good you know I was talking one of my
friends a few years ago I was asking him
what do you want to be doing in five or
ten years oh it's really clear I want to
be an entrepreneur that's like saying I
want to be rich I want to be famous and
I don't think I don't those are what
those are good things being rich and
famous or common they're not good as
direct goals like if you if you have
that as your sole goal you're unlikely
to I think really really succeed and so
I think you become an entrepreneur
because you're working on an important
problem nobody else is working on I
think you should start a business if you
have something if you're if you're
working on a problem that otherwise
would not get solved number six is keep
on going with Mark Zuckerberg it wasn't
so long ago that you know I was a
student and you know sitting in in a
seat in an auditorium like you guys are
here today listening to I remember very
specifically this time when Bill Gates
came to talk it at Harvard and I'm like
wow how do you how do you do that and
but you know the trick is is that the
media likes to sensationalize this as if
you have some Eureka moment or you are
some singular person who can't build
something on your own and that's just
not how the world works you know
when I was in school I built a lot of
stuff that I just like building there
was not a single moment when I when I
had some revelation that Facebook was
gonna be awesome
that's not maybe how the media or movies
or whatever would like to portray things
it's not it's much less exciting but the
reality is I think most eye services in
the world that reach the scale that
Facebook has you start off building
something that you care about and you
know you don't necessarily think it's
gonna be that big I I didn't you know I
built Facebook the first version of
Facebook for my college community
because I wanted to be able to connect
with the people at my school and I
remember very clearly talking to my
friends at the time and saying you know
it's how cool is it that we have built
this community for our school you know
one day it's gonna be awesome when
somebody else builds this for the world
because something like this needs to
exist for the world but it didn't even
occur to me that you know my friends and
I might be able to play a role in doing
that because we were college students
all right I mean we didn't have any you
know engineers to work with or servers
or resources or anything like that and
you know there were these huge companies
that deliver products for hundreds of
millions of people right there's new
hires assumed that it was gonna be like
Microsoft or Google or someone would
build this for the world and what
basically just happened is that each
step along the way we just kind of kept
doing the next thing and growing from
there and you know there were teams
inside these other companies that that
thought social media was important and
we're working on it but there were all
these different memes and narratives in
the world you know people would say oh
well you know this is just a fad people
are gonna use it but then they're gonna
stop so you know so a lot of the teams
who were working on didn't
that seriously or you know the the
higher-ups and those companies didn't
care so then get resources and we just
kept going and going and then people
would say alright well alright fine so
maybe people are using it but it's never
gonna make any money alright I mean
social media doesn't make any money
yeah we just kind of kept going and
going and then pretty soon we had a
service that was bigger than any of
these other ones and that kind of is how
we are here where we are there's no
magic a lot of times I think people just
get afraid because you know often your
dream is its it seems like it's so so
far off but but if you just kind of
focus on building stuff that you think
is good and and you keep on going at
each step along the way and don't let
people deter you from that and you just
really care about what you're doing and
kind of don't give up but each step
along the way then you know I think
that's how you that's how you build
something good
number seven is focus on the efficiency
with Jack Ma in the future people you
will not make money but make money by
the service you offer you know how good
service you do it's going to be how
efficient you are and Alibaba we we our
company right now have twenty does not
including the Financial Group we have a
twenty five units
twenty-five different business units
maybe in the future we might have 50 I
don't know right we have done many units
and we are almost in everywhere we
control our head counts by efficiency we
have we only have to 24 to the four
thousand people I tell your story last
the thing I feel proud of the two years
ago we we start to have a budgeting
meeting and I asked my team well year
2012 if we want to double all the
numbers we have how many people we need
and people say seven thousand eight
hundred new people I said no no no check
it again and then they say six hundred
eight hundred people as you know and
they might my people ask me how many you
want
I said 200 there's no impossible 200
my answer is our four years we discuss
we should hire more people for future
I've heard this for 10 years now let's
let's let's just do the efficient thing
and I told all the management if we have
net income net you know had come over
200 even one people we should have no
bonus for a whole year for year 2012 and
then we started start the plan year 2012
we net lose 1,000 people or the number
doubled and I say if we want to create
more jobs for the others
let's keep our head accounts make sure
because right now we have over 500
minute registered users on top up no
matter how many people we hire ourself
we cannot be it's always not enough
people so we can focus on technology
focusing on making sure the platform is
efficiency focusing everybody makes the
difference in the platform that would
make the difference number 8 is get out
of your comfort zone with Richard
Branson it looks like you always go out
of your comfort zone right coming onto
an island that was completely deserted
no fresh water you don't even have the
money to buy it and and now you're
sleeping on a tent on the beach trying
to figure out how to get fresh water
here you do that often you did it with
the airline I mean I was just somebody
that experienced the bad experience of
traveling on Airlines I was actually
trying to get to the BVI the British
Virgin Islands one day from Puerto Rico
and the same lovely lady was waiting for
me and I've been away for three weeks
and American Airlines bumped the flight
and and so I went to the back of the
airport I had a plane I had a black
board I wrote Virgin Airlines one-way
$29 to the VV I went around all the
people have been bumped and I filled my
first plane and and that got me thinking
you know that airlines do bump people
they don't care about your me
particularly in the air and so we saw
them
bowing and said you have any second
seven four seven okay I mean it was
literally that you just sat in the
airport and said I'm starting an airline
right now because I'm frustrated exactly
and I think most most of the best
entrepreneurial ideas come out of
frustration I think you know if you if
you're frustrated about something and
the best way of sorting it out is get
out and do it and you've got yourself a
business number nine is simplified
complexity with Jack Dorsey my goal is
to simplify complexity I just want to
build stuff that really simplifies our
base human interaction twitter was
around communication and visualizing
what was happening in the world in real
time Square was allowing everyone to
accept the form of payment that people
have in our pocket today which is a
credit card so we've built the simplest
way to accept credit cards and it's just
this little tiny device that we give
away for free and you just download some
software from the App Store and you plug
it in to your mobile phone or your iPad
and suddenly you can take credit cards
so if you're a tax accountant or a
lawyer or a doctor or you know even a
hairstylist you can now accept credit
cards and number ten is trust yourself
with Robert F Smith running your own
race demands trusting yourself even when
others don't because guess what there
are a lot of people good people people
who love you who trust you and who you
love and trust who want the best for you
and you'll come to them with some ideas
about what you want to do and how you
want to do it and they're gonna say
that's crazy just like when I left my
first engineering job at Kraft and was
telling my grandfather I was going back
to business school and he said that's a
great paying job that's crazy and when I
finished Business School and decided to
join the tumultuous world of Investment
Banking my friends and my family and it
was spoke up with concerns about my
sanity and when I left goldman sachs
right after we've gone public to set up
a private equity firm called vista my
mentors and colleagues at goldman sachs
thought i was crazy and to top it all
off when i told i'm gonna start a firm
we're gonna focus on enterprise software
and not be diversified like all other
private equity firms I was gonna hire a
team of smart young talented people who
never done this before everyone knew I
was certifiable and I did this of course
in the spring of 2000 about two months
before the entire tech bubble crashed
well all I can tell you is I've never
been mad at these folks in fact I'm
grateful for the advice and their
concern because in their caution I found
my courage in their doubts I found my
resolve and in their warning warnings I
found my voice and charted my own
journey and I'm proud of the vistas
story we take risks we do things
differently and we listen to our own
voice we run our own race and it has
worked we are now considered to be the
number one private equity firm on the
planet and have been so for the last
decade thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed I'd love to
know what was the single biggest
takeaway that you took from this video
that you're going to apply immediately
somehow to your life or to your business
leave it down the count's below when you
do that and you write it down it's much
more likely to stick up here as well
which is what we want I also want to
give a quick shout out to deliver for
picking up a copy of my book the top ten
rules a success and posting it to your
Instagram account and tagging me I
really really appreciate it and I hope
you enjoy the read so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you
I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever you're one where
it is much love I'll see you soon
[Music]
yeah the most important work ever if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums your Apple
that would be to like a little beacon
hey believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details
[Music]